what if I have no customers how can I do
this survey and reverse segmentation of
the customers to figure all this stuff
out there's a reason that y combinator
one of the best startup incubators out
there picks Founders who have past
experience in the industry that they're
trying to pursue because there's a lot
of depth of experience that just comes
through osmosis from being in an
industry for a long period of time you'd
be amazed that if your father was a
mechanic how much you know about cars
just by growing up in a household where
your father does a certain thing we
always want to pick the people that we
feel like we can serve the most and
create the most value for so if you were
like I don't know I have three different
backgrounds it's like okay well of those
three different people which of those
subsets do you think you could help the
most that's the person you should help
because if you can help that person the
most it means that you can charge the
most and ultimately make the most money
if you're worried about like wouldn't
that mean I'm only going to be able to
serve a very narrow customer that's the
point because you're not going to try
and compete with the biggest companies
in the world who already have all the
operational infrastructure to crush you
you're just going to say I'm going to go
laser focused on this one person and I
think that I could be the best company
in the world at this tiny slice